before we say goodbye we'd love to play
a quick round of truth or dare
and since we're celebrating scream today
we actually have two huge scream fans
here it's jenna and destiny
now in truth or dare usually i'll say or
do anything because i'm game
um but actually i'm gonna hand this one
over to you today
take it away thank you
i wrote a little something because i uh
i write a lot i write a lot of poetry
but i knew today i needed a little help
destiny oh god
our story is one of growth communication
unwavering support and love
we might not have started because of
scream
but our
journey and our love has flourished
through all the adventures and the
amazing people that we've met along the
way
we are here because of all of those
people
and you
um and and just everybody that lifted us
up
now i know you were bummed um because
you didn't have a family heirloom
to pass down between you and your
brothers from your grandma once you
passed
but your mom had that taken care of
behind the scenes
it is an honor to have this opportunity
and an even bigger one to ask you this
with the ring that belonged to your
favorite person your grandma
i am so lucky
and we are so lucky
so destiny justine
oh god
will you marry me
of course yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm
[Applause]
and you know what's so beautiful
is that you choose each other
you know
and
that's that's the hope for all of us you
know
that we might get to choose somebody or
that somebody chooses us to choose to
love to be brave enough to love to show
that love thank you for doing it here
with us today it's such an honor no it's
an honor
thank you so much
thank you for choosing to spend your
time with us we make this show for you
so
take it with you
[Applause]
[Music]